KATHRYN SHIH: Almost
everyone on the Studio team
has a development
background, so we're all
very familiar with the love/hate
relationship you build up
with the tools you use.
And that's why we
started building Studio,
because we wanted it to
be as easy as possible
to ship Android apps.
But, of course, I'm saying
this because I'm on the team.
So instead of
listening to me, we
asked a bunch of
Android developers
why they choose to use Studio.
MATT LAROCHE: The reason
our team at Strava
uses Android Studio is because
it's built for Android.
The new emulator feels
like using a phone,
but it's on your computer.
For a long time,
what we were doing is
we were deploying to
our phone in our hand,
then looking up at the
screen, looking down.
It's even faster to just
look next to your IDE
and see it on your screen.
Getting the latest
from Google is
kind of like sitting
outside of their office
and asking for an update,
but a little easier.
SRDJAN PANTIC: I'm a member of
the Android team in Netflix.
And we are using the
Android Studio as best way
to develop Netflix
app on Android.
You don't really think
about core checks
until you need them, right?
So, for example, you're
trying to look up the string,
and you pass
integer value to it.
That's example, and
Android Studio core check
would actually find
the potential problem
that you will have.
SOFIYA TASKOVA:
Android Studio helps
me remember where I came
from and where I want to go.
It keeps me in the flow,
so I can code faster.
I use a lot of the
little shortcuts,
like find usages or
go to whatever classes
extend the current class.
The navigation that
I use on it keeps
a sort of replica of
my trail of thoughts.
All these shortcuts help
me fly through the code.
And at Hipmunk, we love to fly.
KATHRYN SHIH: All of the
professional Android developers
we talk to use Android
Studio for their apps.
And their feedback has
been really important
for us to know to focus on
things like speed, smarts,
and platform support.
Our hope is that this lets them
spend their time concentrating
on building amazing experiences
for their end users.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT LAROCHE: I don't
understand, like,
why this video exists.
It's like, Android
Studio is really good.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like, what else
are you going to use?